serious war is a mess after six years
the conflict is divided between four
sides each side with foreign backers and
those foreign backers don't even agree
with each other on who they're fighting
for and who they're fighting against and
now Syria's use of chemical weapons has
provoked President Donald Trump to
directly attack Syrian President Bashar
al-assad this is a major development
because up until now the US has only
been focused on fighting Isis to
understand the criss-crossing
interventions and battle lines in Syria
today and how it got this way it helps
to go back to the beginning of the
conflict and watch to see how it
unfolded the first shots in the war were
fired in March 2011 by Syrian dictator
Bashar al-assad against peaceful Arab
Spring demonstrators in July the
protesters start shooting back and some
Syrian troops even defect from the
Syrian army to join them they call
themselves the Free Syrian Army and the
uprising becomes a civil war extremists
from around the region and the world
start traveling to Syria to join the
rebels now Assad actually encourages
this by releasing jihadist prisoners to
tinge the rebellion with extremism and
make it harder for foreign backers to
support them in January 2012 al-qaeda
forms a new branch in Syria Chabad
al-nusra also around that time Syrian
Kurdish groups who have long sought
autonomy take up arms and informally
secede from Assad's rule in the north
that summer is when Syria becomes a
proxy war Iran Assad's most important
ally intervenes on his behalf and by the
end of 2012 Iran is sending daily cargo
flights and has hundreds of officers on
the ground at the same time the oil-rich
arab states in the persian gulf begins
sending money and weapons to the rebels
mainly to counter Iran's influence
[Music]
Iran steps up its influence in turn in
mid-2012 when Hezbollah a Lebanese
militia backed by Iran invades to fight
along Assad in turn the Gulf states
respond Saudi Arabia really stepping up
this time to send more money in weapons
to the rebels this time through Jordan
who also opposes Assad by 2013 the
Middle East is divided between mostly
Sunni powers generally supporting the
rebels and Shias generally supporting
Assad that April the Obama
administration horrified by Assad's
atrocities and the mounting death toll
signs a secret order authorizing the CIA
to train and equip Syrian rebels but the
program stalls at the same time the US
quietly urges Arab Gulf states to stop
funding extremists but their requests
basically go ignored in August the Assad
regime uses chemical weapons against
civilians provoking condemnation
men women children lying in rows killed
by poison gas it is in the national
security interests of the United States
to respond to the Assad regime's use of
chemical weapons through a targeted
military strike Russia proposed on
Monday the serious of surrender control
over its chemical weapons to the
international community for its eventual
dismantling to avoid a US military
strike the US ends up backing down but
the whole thing establishes Syria as a
Great Powers dispute with Russia backing
Assad and the u.s. opposing him just
weeks later the first American CIA
training and arms reach Syrian rebels
the u.s. is now a participant in the war
in February 2014 something happens that
transforms the war an al-qaeda affiliate
based mostly in Iraq breaks away from
the group over internal disagreements
the group calls itself the Islamic State
of Iraq and Syria or Isis and it becomes
al Qaeda's enemy Isis mostly fights not
Assad but other rebels and Kurds carving
out a mini state it calls its Caliphate
that summer it marches across Iraq
seizing territory and galvanizing the
world against it in September one year
after us almost bombed Assad it begins
bombing Isis moving ahead with our
campaign of airstrikes against these
terrorists and were prepared to take
action against ISIL in Syria as well
that summer in July the Pentagon
launches its own program to train Syrian
rebels but will only train those who
will fight Isis not Assad the program
fizzles showing that America now opposes
Isis more than Assad but that there's
also no like-minded Syrian proxy forces
on the ground in Syria in August
turkey starts bombing Kurdish groups in
Iraq and in Turkey even as these Kurdish
groups are fighting Isis in Syria but
turkey doesn't bomb Isis this gets to
one of the big problems in this conflict
the u.s. sees Isis as its main enemy but
the US has allies the turkey in a lot of
middle eastern states have other
priorities this makes for a lot of
unclear and confusing alliances the next
month in September Russia intervenes on
behalf of Assad sending a few dozen
military aircraft to a long-held Russian
base in the country Russia says it's
there to bomb Isis but in fact only ends
up bombing anti-assad rebels including
some backed by the US the next year
Donald Trump wins the White House vowing
to stay out of Syria and signaling that
Assad should be able to stay in power at
the end of 2016
Assad helped by Russian air power and
Iranian sponsored militias retakes the
Syrian city of Aleppo knocking the
rebels out of their last remaining urban
stronghold
then in spring 2017 Assad once again
uses chemical weapons against his people
killing 85 including 20 children back in
the US Trump says his attitude toward
Syria and Assad has quote changed very
much due to the attacks he vows to
respond and within just a few days the
White House launches dozens of Tomahawk
missiles that strike an airbase in Syria
this is the first time the United States
has directly attacked the Assad regime
and this adds yet another criss-crossing
complication to the arty
multi-dimensional civil war so as it
stands now Syria is in ruins even as
Assad recaptures land the rebellion
persevered and with outside countries
fueling each of the groups it's clear
that there's still no end in sight
[Music]